what's up with the gun keep that where I  can see it  all right  good afternoon thank you so much for  joining us here at noon I'm Kirsten  Joyce our other top story new video  showing the Fatal police shooting of an  ex-marine who aimed an assault rifle at  police 38-year-old Darren Dyer was shot  and killed in his backyard in North Las  Vegas September 24th police say a  neighbor called 9-1-1 reporting that  Dyer was trying to break into a home  holding a gun and making threats the  video shows a brief exchange of words  between Dyer and Sergeant Paul Sanderson  it also shows Dyer holding an AR-15  police say he aimed at them they were  forced to shoot